at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by audible which has the
largest selection of audiobooks on the
planet I've used audible for many years
and I have several audio books to
recommend right off the bat if you're
looking for a new one ready player one
by Ernest Cline you may have heard of it
the town of Seneca by Seneca if you want
to hear my favorite collection of
letters of all time as well as the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman which is a
fiction book I use to reintroduce
nonfiction purists to the beauty and
truth and enjoyment of fiction graveyard
book it is incredible and I like the
version that Neil reads himself but the
entire ensemble cast is also fun audible
members get a credit every month good
for any audiobook you the store
regardless of price and unused credits
roll over to the next month so if you
didn't like your audiobook no problem
you can exchange it no questions asked
plus your books are yours to keep with
audible you can go back and relist in
anytime even if you cancel your
membership and for some books again
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman I've
listened many many times you may even
just start over as soon as you finish it
the first time
audible also helps you to listen to more
books by letting you switch seamlessly
between devices picking up exactly where
you left off whether it's on your phone
through your car from a tablet or at
home on Amazon echo whatever you can get
through tons of books hands and eyes
free while doing almost anything so that
is part of the beauty of audio it is a
secondary activity when you're walking
the dog cooking whatever it might be
audible content includes an unmatched
selection of audiobooks original audio
shows news comedy and much more from
leading audio book publishers
broadcasters entertainers magazine and
newspaper publishers and business
information providers maybe that's what
I am a business information provider and
right now audible is offering listeners
of this podcast a free audio book with a
30 day trial memberships check it out go
to audible
come forward / Tim and browse the
unmatched selection of audio programs
download a title free and start
listening it is super simple go to
audible.com forward slash Tim or text
Tim - 500 500 on your telephone to get
started today
check it out this episode is brought to
you by Inc tel and I've used them
personally ever since I wrote the 4-hour
workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life I use that in investing
as well the second how can I spend a
little money or moderate money to save
significant time Intel is one of those
investments they're a turnkey solution
for all of your imaginable customer care
needs
I used Intel during the launch of the
4-hour body which was very very involved
and they provided 24/7 customer service
for my landrush campaign because it was
critical for me to take care of every
person who purchased my books and
participated this allowed me to focus on
the things that I am better at my
strengths like the marketing plan that
we'd worked on for six months
implementing that Intel trains their
experience customer service reps to know
your business and your products inside
and out and make your customers raving
fans they answer more than a million
customer service requests every year and
they can do so across all platforms
including email phone social media text
even chat leaving your customers with
poor service or just mediocre service
which by the way in a competitive pool
is a huge liability long wait times or
unanswered messages carries a massive
cost and risk to your business Intel
removes the logistics and headaches of
this type of communication allowing you
to focus on your strengths and grow your
business it can be a real competitive
advantage and I see many many e-commerce
companies and tech companies thinking of
customer service as a good enough check
box or an afterthought and just like
Airbnb used design in innovative ways to
be
a competitor and to win you can do the
same thing with customer service so as a
listener of this podcast you can get up
to ten thousand dollars off that's a big
discount ten thousand dollars off your
startup fees and costs by visiting Inc
Telkom forward slash Tim so check it out
for more info go to Inc Telkom i NK te l
comm forward slash tim hello boys and
girls this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers to tease out the
habits routines etc that you can use in
your life and this episode is a four or
five for the price of one which is free
but four or five for the price of one
because my guest is none other than
Doris Kearns Goodwin who could be found
at Doris Kearns Goodwin that's ke a RN s
Doris Kearns Goodwin comm also on
Facebook and on Twitter at Doris ke
Goodwin who is Doris let me begin with
some background Doris's interest in
leadership began more than a
half-century ago as a professor at
Harvard her experiences working for LBJ
in the White House and later assisting
him on his memoirs led to Lyndon Johnson
and the American dream she followed that
up with the Pulitzer Prize winning no
ordinary time subtitle Franklin and
Eleanor and the homefront in World War
two she then earned the Lincoln prize
for the runaway bestseller team of
rivals and for those of you who don't
recognize that book title you might
recognize it as the basis for Steven
Spielberg's award-winning film Lincoln
and she then won the carnegie medal for
the bully pulpit the chronicle of the
friendship between Theodore Roosevelt
and William Howard Taft her newest book
is leadership in turbulent times and I
love this book because it goes all the
way back to the very beginning and looks
at how the four presidents she studied
most closely Abraham Lincoln Theodore
Roosevelt FDR and LBJ how they found
their footing goes all the way back to
their first entries into public life and
we encounter them at a time when their
paths were filled with can few
uncertainty fear and hope how did they
establish themselves as leaders what did
other people recognize in them but also
how did they manage their lives day to
day how did they get to sleep were there
any tricks that they used any social
conventions or rituals that they use to
maintain composure in the hardest of
times we dig into all of that and as
such we get all sorts of tidbits and
life lessons from not just Doris we do
talk about her life as well but these
presidents she has studied so in depth
and with that I had a blast with this
episode and let's just get right to it
without further ado please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with Doris
Kearns Goodwin
Doris welcome to the show I have been
looking forward to this conversation and
also very intimidated by this
conversation in my prep and in doing all
of my homework so I'm going to apologize
in advance to you and my listeners if I
embarrass myself with my lack of domain
expertise as we we get into many
different things but I thought we could
start with something that does not
intimidate me and that is some of your
very early childhood experiences I had
read in the course of doing preparation
for this conversation that your father
was an optimist and his optimism was
perhaps the greatest or one of the
greatest gifts that he gave you could
you perhaps just set the set the scene
and explain some of the circumstances
and then also what that meant to to
instill optimism in you no I do indeed
feel like it was the greatest gift he
could have given me he had a very
difficult life which I learned about of
course when I was a little girl but
never having met his parents or
grandparents grandparents had come over
from Ireland and then my father was
orphaned when he was 10 years old his
little brother was hit by a trolley car
when my father was 10 the little boy was
6 his mother was pregnant he had a
two-year-old sister and the little boy
died finally from the trolley accident
his mother had a
child died another child and his sister
and he were then put out to other people
after his mother died in childbirth his
father committed suicide
I learned this all later so here's this
man Michael Francis Aloysius Kearns 10
years old goes to work very early
eventually becomes a bank examiner in
New York State was great with numbers
something that he did not give me as a
gift but most importantly he somehow if
you saw that man you would never know
that sadness that he had in his
childhood he had a twinkle in his eye he
loved life he gave me that optimistic
spirit telling me if you like people
people will like you in turn and I it's
been the way my life has been led since
then and like it's hard to imagine what
better gift there's confidence that I
think you'd get from your family and I
think I got that too but the ability to
just get through adversities with
resilience and to have that hopeful
feeling that things are going to turn
out all right even though sometimes they
don't you think they will again it
sustained me through my whole life are
there any particular examples that you
can think of or just approaches that you
remember your father taking to coach you
through difficult times or difficult
experiences when you were perhaps not at
the peak of confidence when you're
suffering hardships what approach would
he have taken or did he take well I
think you know in small and large ways I
remember once I was in a concert at
school and I was we were singing Old Man
River and by mistake I instead of saying
said of singing Old Man River instead of
saying he's tired of living and scared
of dying
I said he's tired of dying and scared of
living I'm so embarrassed and after I
came out I said it was much deeper what
you said he's hot is that pink red and
we went and had some ice cream you know
and then of course because I was such a
huge baseball fan I had to get through
the failure of the Dodgers year after
year after year the Brooklyn Dodgers and
again he just said it will happen some
year and he made me feel that way too
next year will happen but probably more
importantly my mother had had rheumatic
fever as a child so she had a damaged
heart and really was an invalid for most
of my childhood and so he saw what I had
to go through and what he had to go
through where she was not well she had
several small heart attacks and again he
just got her through it got me through
it and it all sounds so sad what I'm
saying but my childhood bizarrely was
not sad and I think it had a lot to do
with him you also mentioned and part of
the reason for people listening that I'm
asking these questions and I'm so
interested in you as a person is that
you are such a keen observer and that's
reflected in your writing certainly
reflected in your speaking as well and
I'm I'm interested in the formation of
your character and strengths and so on
baseball
you mentioned baseball I don't know much
about your background of baseball but is
it true and I can't believe everything I
read on the internet so I certainly
stand to be fat correct at any time that
you were the first woman to be invited
into the Red Sox locker room is that
true
I don't know about the first woman to be
invited in but I was the first
journalist to be the journalist I
happened to be at spring training on the
day that the order came down from the
court saying that women journalists had
to be allowed into the locker room to be
able to do their job so the owners of
the Red Sox said go in so it happened
that I was the first person to go in and
it actually is a Trivial Pursuit
question in the New England Trivial
Pursuit day so it's a it's a great pride
to have done it it wasn't that exciting
to be honest I didn't see lots of guys
in matters of undress because they but
they were I was there and I didn't even
have to interview them I just had to say
I was there I'm okay have you always
been a as long as you can remember a an
aficionado of baseball how did that
develop I think in so many ways my love
of history came from my love of baseball
my father had grown up in Brooklyn and
then moved to Long Island just before I
was born but still loved the Brooklyn
Dodgers so when I was only five six
years old he taught me that mysterious
art of keeping score while listening to
baseball games
so that I could record for him like on a
summer afternoon the history of that
afternoon's Brooklyn Dodger game and
then he would come home from work on the
Long Island train at night and I would
recount for him with all my miniaturized
symbols the K for strikeout getting the
guy around the bases I could tell him
every play of every inning of the game
that had taken place and he made me feel
I was telling him a fabulous story so it
makes you think even as a little girl
there's something magic about history to
keep your father's attention for so long
in fact I'm convinced I learned the
narrative art from those nightly
sessions with my dad because at first
I'd be so excited before I went into
this huge rendition I would say the
Dodgers water the Dodgers lost which
took the drama of this two-hour telling
away so I finally learned you had to
tell a story from beginning to middle to
end he made it even more special for me
when I was six he never told me then
that all of this was actually described
in great detail in the sports pages of
the newspapers the next day so I thought
without me he wouldn't even know what
happened to the Brooklyn Dodgers so it
really did I think teach me the
importance of telling a story in fact
much later I read an essay by my heroine
Barbara Tuchman and she said even if
you're writing about a war as a
narrative historian you have to imagine
to yourself you do not know how that war
ended so you can carry your reader with
you every step along the way from
beginning to middle and not being an
all-knowing person that says oh they won
this war what's the drama if you already
know that so I learned that just trying
to keep my father's attention and
telling him the story step by step of
what happened to the Dodgers that day
for those who don't know who is Barbara
Tuchman Robert Tuchman is a female
historian and I only mentioned female
historian of course she was a very
important early female Pulitzer
prize-winning historian and I read a
book that she wrote tons of August when
I was in college and it was so
beautifully written but more importantly
for me she was writing about battles and
military stuff and things that you don't
imagine that sometimes a woman might be
so adept at but more importantly she was
just a beautiful storyteller and writer
so I met her later but she became a
mentor in my imagination I think when I
was in college now the point at which
history enters the scene as such
labeled as such even if baseball and
your your experiences with your father
perhaps introduced you to crafting this
in this narrative arc did that start in
high school I had read I don't know if
that's true or not but I'd read that you
had a fantastic history teacher in high
school who I think won an award for best
history teacher in New York State or
something along those lines was was that
a very influential period for you and
when you were specifically in that class
or where there did history somehow enter
the picture prior to that well I think
beyond baseball the other experience
that led me to love stories from the
past is because my mother had had
rheumatic fever and had this damaged
heart I'd love to listen to her tell
stories I kept saying to her mom tell me
stories about you and you were a young
girl like me I somehow thought if I
could keep her mind talking about days
when she was young before her illness
set in that her mind would control her
body and this premature aging process we
were witnessing would be stopped in its
tracks stop is constantly saying mom
tell me a story about you when you were
my age not realizing how peculiar that
was until my own three sons never once
said to me mom tell us a story about you
and you're our age but I think it again
it instilled in me the idea that stories
from the past can can bring people who
are different alive when they were
younger and then of course when I ended
up studying dead residents trying to
bring them to life so these two roots I
think of my father's love of baseball
and my wish that my mother could be
younger and I could imagine her running
up the steps two at a time led to my
interest in the past but then I think
when I got to high school a wonderful
high school in Long Island South Side
senior high school this teacher Miss
Austin was the head of the social
studies department she made you feel
when she was telling her about FDR's
death as if she were experiencing it you
know her eyes filled up and she did
indeed when an award is the best history
teacher in New York State so all of us
benefited by having that chance to see
history come alive I love history so
much now and I just wish that every kid
in school would have a teacher with that
kind of passion because whenever I hear
kids say oh it's boring it's just a
bunch of facts
and I keep thinking no it's about people
who lived before they had drama in their
lives they they went through tough times
our country went through tough times and
the more you can learn from that
perspective just like learning from your
parents or grandparents you're learning
from generations ago and if I could just
have a Miss Austen in every school in
America that would be my dream when did
you decide that you wanted to explore
biography as as supposed to you're one
of your many explorations of literature
and as a writer when when did that first
come onto your radar or did you first
think of it no I think we're biography
came from was Lyndon Johnson when I was
in graduate school and in college I was
really interested in the Supreme Court
and thought I might actually go to law
school rather than graduate school but I
did end up going to graduate school and
I had a great teacher at Harvard
Graduate School who taught the history
of the Supreme Court so my PhD thesis
was on Supreme Court so I might have
been studying these guys in their robes
rather than my dead presidents were it
not for the fact that I got a White
House fellowship and a wonderful program
that still exists today which takes
people from 23 to 48 or 50 perhaps and
brings them to Washington for a year
hoping that you'll get a sense of the
government and then go back to your
private life you know having been
enriched by that experience and I was at
the young end I was only 24 when I was
chosen and ended up in a peculiar way
working for Lyndon Johnson and then
helping him on his memoirs the last
years of his life and then writing my
first book on Lyndon Johnson so that's
what set me into presidential history
that's what sent me into biography that
random experience I mean chance plays a
role in so much of our lives I think I
in the course of prepping for this read
that I you had some doubts about whether
you would remain in the White House and
I'm paraphrasing here I'm pulling from
memory which isn't always my strong suit
because you had written an anti-war
piece and that
I guess at the time that the president
decided to keep you around and that if
he couldn't convert you nobody could and
I'm just wondering a if you could flesh
that out a little bit and be why he
would make that type of decision yes
what happened is when we were chosen as
White House fellows there was a big
dance at the White House and he did
dance with me that night not that
peculiar there were only three women out
of the sixteen White House fellows but
as he twirled me around the floor he
whispered that he wanted me to be
assigned directly to him but it was not
to be that simple for in the months
prior to my selection as a White House
Fellow like many young people I was
active in the anti-vietnam war movement
and had written an article with a friend
of mine that we had sent to the New
Republic weeks before and had not heard
anything back on the need for a
third-party candidate to challenge
Lyndon Johnson so it came out with the
title two days after the dance in the
White House how to remove Lyndon Johnson
from power oh my god I was certainly out
of the program or even worse he might
destroy the entire program but instead
surprisingly he said Oh bring her down
here for a year and if I can't win her
over no one can so I was not assigned
directly to him in the White House
though I think I was too in said theory
for that so I was assigned to the Labor
Department under Willard works it was a
wonderful mentor and then Johnson
withdrew from the race in March of 1968
and right after he would through from
the race he called me the White House
and he said well you said I should be
removed from office
I've now removed myself now you have to
work for me the rest of the time and so
I did I went to the White House and then
as I say he asked me when the White
House fellowship and the year working
for him came to an end to help a company
in part time to his ranch to help him on
his memoirs he wanted me to come
full-time but I knew enough about Lyndon
Johnson then that if you were completely
in his way it was really hard to keep
your own sense of balance so I asked him
if I could just go part-time and go back
to Harvard to start teaching which is
what I wanted to do and at first he said
no all or nothing all or nothing so then
the last day when he was in the White
House and he was going to leave the next
day he called me back and just said okay
it's all
come part-time and then he just got to
me he said you know it's not so easy
when you're not in power in the same way
to get what you want I I won't forget
that you're doing this but just don't
let those Harvard's poison your feeling
about me so that was the extraordinary
experience I stayed at the ranch much of
the time I was there got to know Lady
Bird got to know him very well and and
felt a great deal of empathy for him
even though he never changed my mind
about the war
I did see extraordinary success that he
had had in the great society and in
civil rights and I saw him struggle with
how he would be remembered in those last
days and last last years of his life so
it was a very emotional experience led
to my first book Lyndon Johnson and then
from there I became a presidential
historian somehow it wasn't that I set
out to become one what an incredible
opportunity I wonder and this is I love
to ask you if if just in an alternate
universe I were able to ask him directly
why he asked you to help him what do you
think he would say I mean he could have
reached out to any number of people what
did he what did he see in you or how
would he answer that question do you
think well you know he had a number of
other people that were working on the
memoirs with him but I think to some
extent because I was young and he knew
that the audience he wanted to reach
were those young people because he felt
that they hadn't understood him even
though he liked to believe he had done
so much for them which he had except for
this except for this huge thing the
Vietnam War he I was a woman so maybe it
was easier to be able to talk to me as a
woman and he knew that I loved listening
to stories and he was a great
storyteller I mean fabulous colorful
anecdotal stories there was a problem
with these stories I later discovered
that half of them weren't true but I
loved listening nonetheless so I think
part of my attraction for him was that I
loved listening to his tall tales there
was also a moment when I worried that
part of the reason he had me there was
because I was a young woman because and
but everything was perfect I kept
talking to him about steady boyfriends
even when I had no boyfriends at all
until one day he decided to have a
discussion he said about our
relationship which sounded ominous when
he took me nearby to the lake
conveniently called Lake Lyndon Baines
Johnson there's
wine and cheese and a red check table
cause all the romantic trappings and he
starts out Doris more than any other
woman I have ever known and my heart
sank
and then he said you remind me of my
mother what's going on in my mind but
nonetheless I was there you know we used
to walk on the ranch I talk about this
actually in the epilogue of my new book
because I tried to bring all four of my
guys Lincoln Teddy Franklin and LBJ to
the whole question of how they wanted to
be remembered over time so I described a
lot of the scenes of walking with him
every day where he his mind was just
going back over the happier parts of his
life and also the sadness of knowing
that hopefully the the sadness of
knowing that the Vietnam War had cut his
legacy in two but hoping that what he
did on civil rights would receive some
sort of bounty in the time to come and
it certainly did and it has but he died
before knowing that for sure when you
mentioned earlier and I'm paraphrasing
here but the referring to your decision
or your priority of doing working with
him hard time you said something along
the lines of it when when you're fully
in his sway it was hard to maintain
balance so I decided to or asked for
part time what does that mean if you
could elaborate on that you know I think
what it means is that he was so powerful
that you had a feeling sometimes that
you couldn't get away from him he wanted
me to be there every moment I mean even
when he took a nap he would want me to
be sitting in a chair right outside the
closet just in case something happened
to him or just not wanting to be alone
and this was a man who needed company
and you know you felt in some ways like
at 24 years old am I going to be able to
you know to say no I want to go to the
movies tonight or I want to I just need
some time or I want to read even though
it was an extraordinary thing to be in
his presence I remember one time in
particular you just sparked this memory
which I haven't thought about when he
would have visitors to the ranch he
would take them in his car and show them
the jumping antelope bluebonnets all
he'd narrate the whole beauty of the
ranch
and when I was first working down there
I'd be in the front of the car with him
it could be an important person in the
back like Dean Rusk or something and
he'd say to me look Doris look at the
jumping antelopes but then I remember
one weekend I didn't go to visit him at
the ranch and I think he was mad that I
hadn't gone because I'd stayed stayed at
Harvard so the next time I was down I
was in the back of the car and he's
saying to whoever's in the front of the
car look look at the job you know I felt
like I was in Siberia that's the matter
with me I don't even want to be in this
car I've seen these jumping antelope a
thousand times that was one of the times
I think I knew that a small thing could
be transferred into an arc of power and
at least had enough sense to think as
long as I've got myself back at Harvard
and I can come on weekends I can come
vacations it really was perfect and I
also wanted to be back teaching that's
what I'd been preparing for I got my PhD
and I couldn't wait to teach so it was a
balance I think between the two but it
worked out really well why couldn't you
wait to teach I think I always talked or
since I was a little person telling
stories and I I knew that if I could
teach now the kids at Harvard it was
later than getting them in high school
or elementary school but at least then
if I could make them love history just
as I had that I would be doing something
meaningful because I thought in passing
on that passion and there could be one
or two or three or five kids in the
class that might end up really loving
history even if they didn't go into it
maybe for the rest of their lives they'd
be reading history as their an avocation
not their vocation that I would do
something that mattered to me so and I
really love teaching I mean I only
stopped teaching when I got married and
had my kids and couldn't teach and write
and be with the kids at the same time
and it was scary I mean to think of
myself as suddenly becoming a writer
when I was much more sure of my ability
to teach so I left Harvard I had two
kids immediately after I was married my
husband had already had a son from his
first marriage his first wife had died
so all of a sudden I have three boys and
I was finding myself hardly able to get
through the day much less get anything
done so I had to make a choice will I
continue teaching or will I try and be a
writer and so
I love I that time finished the first
book on Lyndon Johnson and was going to
be working on my next book and had a
contract but even then it took me ten
years to finish the next book and I
remember being in a cocktail party in
Cambridge at one point where somebody
said whatever happened to Doris Kearns
anyway did she die I wanted to hit the
person and say I had three boys that's
what's happened to me but it was able to
I was able to balance I think being a
writer better with having the kids then
I could if I were teaching and writing
and having the kids but every now and
then when I lecture and it's a 45-minute
lecture or a 50-minute lecture I think
yes this is what it used to be like 45
minutes is it's a nice self encapsulated
beginning middle and end compared to
perhaps ten years how did were there
times when you didn't see the light at
the end of the tunnel or weren't sure if
you were gonna finish and did you have
any self moments of self-doubt over that
ten year span it's a lot a long period
of time in fact each of my books have
taken such a long period of time that
there are certainly moments where you
just think what am i doing I mean the
book about Franklin and Eleanor and
World War two took longer to write then
it took the war to be fought which is
really embarrassing and the book on
teddy intact took seven years and the
book on Lincoln took nearly ten years
the reason it's not as scary as it might
sound is that I always sort of have an
outline of knowing what I want to do
before I start it's sort of the
laypersons I don't know that much about
the person so I want to know what do
people want to know about them I'm not
that much of an expert on the person
when I start and and then I start
building the book usually
chronologically if not from their
childhood wherever I'm starting so
chapters get done so it's not like I
spend five years researching and then
start writing again Barbara Tuchman my
heroine said you've got to start writing
as soon as you can because otherwise
you'll really feel this mass of material
is unable to being worked on so yes sure
there were times but on the other hand
it meant that I could have my own hours
my husband's was a writer and we both
wrote at home I didn't have to travel
anywhere to go and do what I was doing
and
faculty meetings at night I could be
with the kids I could go to the Little
League games and I really appreciated
that I was now in a profession that
allowed me to balance as much as I could
even if it meant I wouldn't produce 40
books I sometimes think what if I you
know had been a man living in another
time and I wasn't involved with the kids
I mean it's a sad thing to think about
maybe I would have produced more books
but I would never trade it oh I think I
think you're doing spectacularly I have
I've as I was mentioning earlier such an
incredible level of respect for the work
you've done it's it's very intimidating
on some level seizing me who read the
bully pulpit in which was a very long
book actually 900 pages that she was
reading it at night in bed and she fell
asleep and it broke her nose my new book
is shorter than any of those well let's
let's talk about some of your guys and
perhaps we could we're going to bounce
around quite a bit and we can take this
in just about any direction but I'd love
to perhaps start with a question about
Lincoln and I've read that you've said
what's perhaps most striking about
Lincoln was his emotional intelligence
and temperament can you can you explain
what you mean by that absolutely I mean
I think when we look at the quality of
empathy which I think is in a critical
quality for any leader I think for some
people it's inborn others can develop it
over time but for Lincoln even as a
child when his friends would be putting
hot coals on Turtles to watch them
wriggle he would stop them and say this
isn't right we can't do this or there
are times when he found somebody drunk
in a pit hole and everybody was walking
by the person and he ended up going back
and picking that person up and bringing
him carrying him to a home and you can
see that in him as a child but
it's more than that I just I felt living
in this presence that I could become a
better person I don't always think that
I great respect for the people that I've
written about but there was something
about Lincoln's and even forgetting how
it made him a great leader which it did
he just refused to let resentments
Fester he refused to let himself get
jealous of people I mean it wasn't that
he didn't have the normal human emotions
of jealousy or envy or anger but he said
if you allow those to fester they will
poison you so there would be times when
you know I might be jealous or something
or envious of something and I just
remember I'd say Lincoln would tell me
this isn't doing you any good
you have to stop I mean there's this
extraordinary story of a Stanton who
becomes his more secretary and they had
met when they were in the in the law
practice together in the 1850 Stanton
lived in Cincinnati Lincoln of course is
in Springfield Illinois but Stanton had
a very national reputation had a big
case to be tried in Chicago so they
thought they needed someone of counsel
in Illinois his partner came and looked
at Lincoln thought he'd be finally and
was so excited at the thought of working
with this extraordinary lawyer Stanton
but at the last minute the case got
transferred from Illinois to Cincinnati
so they didn't need Lincoln anymore but
they forgot to tell him so he kept
working on his brief he went to
Cincinnati all on his own he met up with
Stanton and Stanton's partner on the
street corner and he said in his
typically gregarious way let's go up to
the courthouse together in a gang
Stanton took one look at Lincoln he had
a huge stain on his shirt
his hair was disheveled his arm sleeves
were too short for his long arms and
legs and he turned to his partner and
partner said this later and said we have
to lose this long armed eight he will
hurt pence right and Lincoln was
humiliated and they didn't open the
brief he had painstakingly prepared but
the amazing thing is he stayed and
watched the entire trial for a week
because he could see that there was some
brilliance in Stanton and he wanted to
learn from him and he went back to
Springfield Illinois and he said I still
have to learn how to become a better
lawyer so he would stay up later at
night he'd get up earlier in the morning
he taught himself Euclid when he was on
the on the Sun circuit in Illinois but
most much more amazingly so after his
Secretary of War has had to resign
everybody comes to him and said the only
person that can mobilize the north and
mobilize the War Department is Edwin
Stanton he's tough he can be a bully at
times he can be insensitive but he's
your guy and somehow Lincoln was able to
put that past hurt behind him and give
Stanton that most incredibly important
job and Stanton came came out eventually
loving Lincoln more than anyone else on
his family now that's a story that just
tells everything you want to know about
him he said I don't care if somebody
disliked me or like me in the past
if somebody's been guilty of ill
treatment or abuse of me if they're
right at this time in this place they're
the right person for the time I trust
that I'll be able to bring out the best
in them and he did it's really
incredible to hear these types of
stories and and I think that it's worth
digging into perhaps some more examples
and I'd love to get your definition or
how you think about temperament because
I've read you describing temperament as
the greatest separator and presidential
leadership and maybe we could scratch
presidential from that phrase I don't
know but I and I think it was let me get
this right Oliver Wendell Holmes jr. who
said about FDR write a psyche he has a
second class intellect about a first
class temperament what is that what does
that mean to you I think what temperate
means really is your basic stance toward
people toward the world does it do you
if you have the kind of temperament
that's got a certain base of confidence
in it so that you can surround yourself
with people who can argue with you and
question your assumptions if you have a
temperament that allows you to share
credit when something goes well to take
the blame when something goes badly do
you bring out the best in other people
do you make them want to work because
you have a common sense of mission all
of these are the basic way you treat
other people I mean I suppose it is
encompassed in emotional intelligence
but I think you're born with a certain
temperament but you also can develop a
certain temperament over time and I do
think Oliver Wendell Holmes was right I
don't think he was right that FDR had a
second-rate intellect I think
that's defining intellect by academic
excellence and he was a mediocre student
at Harvard a mediocre student at
Columbia Law School but he had an
incredible problem-solving mind and he
had the ability to bring people around
him experts in all the academic fields
and they start out these evenings these
braintrust
evenings where they just relax and tell
funny stories and have a couple drinks
and then he would start questioning them
and he was an incredible questioner and
he could bring out it was almost as if
he was excavating their brain and
whatever he heard by verbal thing he
could remember people remember in very
different ways I mean Lincoln remembered
when he read he had an extraordinary
memory that if he read something over
and over again it would stick in his
brain like a poem or a piece of
Shakespeare's drama FDR learned by
listening to other people and once he
had the story in his own mind he could
then tell it to somebody else so that
and that's intelligence is of a
different sort I think than just doing
well on a series of exams when you're in
school and if we're looking at say
attributes versus skills that are
developed or the nature versus nurture
aspect of some of these abilities or the
temperament as you mentioned if we look
at say and I think I'm getting this
right the Lincoln quote you to your
opponents today may be your allies
tomorrow what was he always that way or
is that something that he developed over
time and became better at no I think he
did develop it over time in fact I think
most of these there are attributes that
may be inborn that are perhaps like
intelligence or maybe even people skills
empathy as I say maybe inborn but the
ability to communicate in some ways but
you can develop all of these as time
goes on and I think that's the important
thing for leaders to understand but in
his case I think when he was younger he
had an extraordinary sense of humor and
he could really take down an opponent by
making fun of him and and he did that on
a couple occasions there was one time
when it the audience loved what he was
doing and making fun of the opponent and
then he saw the opponent opponent
leaving leaving the audience and with
tears in his eyes and he just said to
himself this isn't worth it this is not
the way you do it so he learned from the
experience of feeling guilt at taking
down an opponent that way that if it
were possible to bring him on your side
eventually I mean obviously when he's in
the middle of the war the Confederates
are his opponents but even there when
you look at that second inaugural what
is he doing in that second inaugural
weeks before he dies but saying both
sides you know both sides read the same
Bible both prayed to the same God
neither's prayers were fully answered
where he's acknowledging that the North
had had problems with slavery justices
South had and then with malice toward
none and charity for all let us bind up
the nation's wounds that's the the the
words that say it but what really says
it was that night when he's elected
president in 1860 he knows he's had
least much less experience than any of
his three rivals they were more
celebrated more educated once but
they've been governors they've been
senators Seward chase and Bates and he
realizes I need their help the country
is in peril these are the strongest and
most able men in the country I need them
by my side it brings them into the top
three positions in his cabinet some of
his friends say why are you doing this
we're gonna look like a figurehead
having these strong people around you
and he said I need them and I'll be fine
and at the beginning some of them
thought they were more important than he
was Seward in particular his secretary
of state so what he was running the show
and that Lincoln would be like a
figurehead but then at a certain point
Lincoln saw what Seward was doing he
knew he needed him but he put him in his
place he said I am the president and I
will do this and they too became great
friends and Seward ended up you know
admiring him more than anybody else so I
think he had an internal confidence that
he could bring these opponents into his
midst but it wasn't easy
it meant holding hands with a lot of
them it meant having to chew them out
when they started bringing their anger
toward each other out in public and and
he had to keep going at it it's much
harder than if you have the same people
around you who are all in the same
direction you may not have as many
arguments in as many troubles but he was
able to contain those factions within
his cabinet and then he was containing
it in the country at large because they
each represent
a certain segment of the population
whether it's radical moderate or
conservative so it's an extraordinary
way to do it but the interesting thing
is you know when I've talked to business
leaders a lot of them said they were
able to look maybe maybe not in that
extreme way having those kind of rivals
with you but to understand the
importance of bringing people near you
who really can argue and question your
assumptions there's there's a moment the
same thing with FDR he's in a room with
a bunch of generals early before the war
had even started the Second World War
and he's describing some pet project
that he loved and all of them are
shaking their heads as if well that's
wonderful and he looks over at George
Marshall who eventually of course
becomes the chief of staff and he says
George you're not shaking your head what
do you think and he said well mr.
president I don't agree with you at all
and the room came to a silence and
everybody left in the talk well that's
it for George Marshall and then he
appointed him not long after bringing
him up like 14 names on the list or more
to be the head because he wanted that
kind of person around him so it's that
strength I think that inner confidence
that allows you to do that that's a
critical question in all leadership
capacities do you have any people you
surround yourself with who you know will
speak truth to you or who have wildly
divergent opinions or political
perspectives is that something that you
have proactively built into your life or
did you just have people already who
surrounding you who offer those
opportunities to hear dissenting
opinions you know it's a really
important question I mean I think in my
work so I've had a woman who's been my
research assistants for the last 35
years and she's still working for me
Beth who's my manager my best friend my
partner in a lot of things that we do
together lives in California has worked
with me for the last 18 years and I
trust her I think more than almost
anybody to tell me when something I've
done is not up to par when something
I've written is not as good as it should
be and when when maybe I'm moving in
some different direction
and then my husband and I have a best
friend named Michael Rothschild who was
a writer and a sculptor and lives in
Maine and he has worked with both my
husband and me and we've worked with in
on everything we write together
everything we do together and he's
absolutely honest about this sentence
isn't any good or this you're not making
this clear so that's built in in a
certain sense I'm not sure that I did it
on the purpose but they they are the
kind of people
Beth and Michael and my husband of
course my husband read every single
thing I've written and not only edited
them but would tell me when when I was
going off in a direction that really
wasn't right I remember when I was
working on the book on the Kennedys and
I'd always been interested in medical
history because the my sisters were both
nurses and my brother-in-law was a
doctor and because of my mother's
medical history so John Fitzgerald Rose
Kennedy's father had gone to Harvard
Medical School for a year and I thought
oh this is great I can write a whole
chapter on the state of Medicine in the
1880s you know and then my husband looks
at it and he says but he dropped out of
medical school and he became a
politician why are you doing this and oh
I hated to make that chapter go down to
two pages but he was just dead right but
the other thing that happens that builds
in dissent is that we live in Concord
Massachusetts and ever since the kids
have been grown and the kids are now
joining us because they live back in the
town which I've been talking about later
but anyway we go out every night to eat
in a bar one of this two or three bars
in Concord that the whole gang of us
goes to one one night one the other
night and the next one the next night
and in that group of people there are
Trump supporters there are radical
people there are moderate people and we
argue and talk about politics and I
think it's really important for me to be
able to listen to those other sides when
I'm gonna be talking on television or
thinking about today as opposed to
thinking about the past let's let's say
you're having one of those group
conversations you're at a restaurant
slash bar so there may or may not be
alcohol involved when if things get
heated how do you or other people in the
group are there any particular phrases
you you
or interjections you use to cool things
a little bit if if they start getting to
ad hominem or too heated is there is and
I guess what I'm stretching for here is
if there any tools or phrases approaches
that people might use to create
environments where a group like that can
actually communicate and hear each
other's opinions without it devolving
into a verbal fistfight yeah obviously
you know all over the country right now
it's a difficult situation where some
places you go in bars and they won't
even put the news on because they're
afraid it will rile the people and make
them unhappy so it's it's not been easy
discussions not only this time but we've
had a tribal feeling about Democrats and
Republicans for some time now to Obama
to Clinton to Bush and I guess the best
thing is as long as you can just ask the
people why do you feel that way
what would makes you what parts of him
do you like or do you like this part of
what he's saying or not that and you can
sort of parse it out or they can ask us
you know why did you like Hillary or
what why did you think she'd be okay you
know even though they might have thought
she was a terrible candidate and as long
as you can acknowledge you know that yes
parts of her candidacy didn't work but
this is what I thought she was prepared
for or on the other hand they could say
he touched a chord Trump did and people
who felt they were being left out and
people who felt that there they weren't
being listened to and then and then
sometimes it does sometimes if it gets
too hard then we just say okay let's
have another drink and change the
subject and talk about the Red Sox there
may be some Yankee fans in the group but
usually it's not so not not up here so
the Red Sox are a very calming device
mad at them too because they thought
this summer this summer they're doing
great
so this is what we're discussing in this
type of looking for a different
adjective but still civil as fine civil
discussion civil discourse about some of
these potentially polarizing topics that
is a skill that can be developed you
have to practice but it can be developed
and I'd love to
look back at some of your guys and to
look at perhaps some of the mistakes
failures or roadblocks which I know you
you discuss very very directly in the
new book to maybe give an illustration
of something they they perhaps weren't
very good at then later became good at
just to show us give us some historical
examples of those those early mistakes /
weaknesses / roadblocks and how they
dealt with them well I mean taking both
Teddy Roosevelt and Franklin Roosevelt
for example and both of them had grown
up in an extraordinary privileged
background and both had a certain kind
of snobbishness I think about people who
are not in their class when Teddy
Roosevelt went to Harvard he looked up
the names of potential friends to see if
they were on the Social Register so that
he would know they'd be safe for him to
be friendly with but then interestingly
he always was interested in the outdoors
in fact in part because he was suffering
from terrible asthma as a child so he
had to build the body that would allow
him to become a man and to live on so in
the summers he would go to Maine with
these guides and they were kind of
backwoodsmen guys and he just loved
being with them and he loved asking them
about their lives he had always been
interested in curious in other lives
through literature but now he was seeing
them they knew the woods they knew
things he didn't know and all of a
sudden the fact that he read more books
than they did seemed less important but
even so when he first got into the state
legislature he he was a fiery kind of
character and he went after a judge who
he thought was corrupt and he pounded
his desk and he said terrible things
about him and he got a swelled head
when the judge was was undone by the
newspapers and then he realized that he
becomes so self-important that he
thought the Democrats on the other side
were terrible people he wasn't dealing
with them that only he knew what was
right and as he said I rose like a
rocket and then I fell to the ground and
he finally decided that you had to
compromise and collaborate and be with
other people and learn from them so an
FDR similarly when he first got into the
state
hhor-- he did very well at the beginning
he was organizing a group of people and
he thought that the the Tammany bosses
were all bad people and then he began to
see my god they may be doing some
corrupt things but they also are helping
people in the cities there they the
people who vote for them do it because
they come to their funerals they get
them food they get them food fuel and he
moderated his kind of approach to
politics but that's the thing that you
know what Teddy said at one point was
the great thing about being a politician
more than if he had chosen another field
and I'm not so sure it's true today but
it was then he said a man who takes an
active part in the political life of a
great city is going to be meeting all
sorts of people as a result and that's
what he called fellow-feeling which he
said was essential for any democracy he
said that by by going to places that he
normally wouldn't go he went to
tenements he was a police commissioner
and he roamed the slums at night he was
a civil service commissioner so he
understood what it was like to take an
exam and want to have a job for that
kind of clerkship he was in the army he
had fellow soldiers that he was leading
and he lived with them and this in the
same kind of tent all of that broadened
his experience that he would not have
had as a child and by the time he
reached the presidency he had what he
called that sense of civic life being
marked by understanding other people's
points of view it's the very thing
that's missing in our country today he
said a large part of the rancor of
political and social strife arises from
misunderstanding by one section in one
class they're so cut off from each other
that they don't appreciate each other's
passions and prejudices and because he
had spent time in the West where he went
after his wife and his mother died on
the same day in the same house to escape
his depression he saw cowboys he was a
cowboy and it's that breadth of
experience that I think all leaders need
to can come through curiosity it can
come possibly through reading but it
comes to meeting people of different
sections in different places and that's
what politics and the best sense can do
but today I think they're much more
narrowed down to the people who agree
with them and they don't have that same
broad experience that they used to let's
let's say that there are people in
government listening to this podcast and
I do know that there
a number of senators who subscribe to
the podcast and various policymakers
what are some recommendations you would
have if they want to develop that
broader perspective are there any
particular actions you might suggest any
particular habits that based on the
historical accounts in your research of
these larger-than-life figures that they
could in the current day somehow
incorporate to develop these types of
attributes that we're talking about I do
believe there are I mean think about it
Lincoln used to have ordinary people
come into his office in the morning and
and just talk to him about what they
wanted they wanted a job this is the
days before civil service and he'd
listened to their family discussions
he'd listened to why that clerkship or
that post ministership would matter to
them and after a while his secretaries
Nicolay and hay said to him mr.
president you don't have time for these
ordinary people he said you're wrong I
must never forget the popular assemblage
from which I have come so Teddy
Roosevelt took Whistlestop tours on a
train six weeks in the spring and in the
fall and he went to places where he'd
been defeated as well as places where he
had won and then he would stop the train
at the local station and listen to
newspaper editors you know who would be
criticizing something he was doing he'd
be talking to ordinary people you have
to get out of the office
I mean FDR was not able because of his
paralysis to go around the country as
much as Teddy Roosevelt was but he sent
Eleanor his wife two hundred days a year
she would be going from one New Deal
project to the other seeing which ones
were working towards wasn't bringing him
back stories of people who were hurting
during the Depression the stories that
he needed to really to really work and
LBJ if you look at the way he dealt with
the Congress why was he so brilliant in
getting the two sides of the aisle
together because in the first six months
of his presidency after JFK died he had
every single congressman over in groups
of 30 to the White House they would then
have started with drinks together and
then Lady Bird would take the spouses in
those days on a tour of the mansion
and then they would sit and talk and
then he would call them up at 6:00 in
the morning he'd called them at noon
call even a senator at 2:00 a.m. he said
I hope I didn't wake you up but I just
need your advice and then the senator
says oh no I was just lying here looking
at the ceiling hoping my president would
call but nothing beats spending time
with different people and not letting
your day get filled up just with the
colleagues and the people in the
government itself
I mean FDR said when he was putting over
the papers to the FDR library the first
Presidential Library he said this
millions of papers here of government
talked to one another but the ones I
value the most are the letters from the
people who are telling me their stories
and their opinions of me and what I
should do differently and those are the
ones that I hope people will read as
time goes by so maintaining that
connection whether it's a leader and and
their company and their shareholders or
whether it's a president and their
constituencies and keeping that sense of
understanding and connection directly
that's why FDR was so terrific on the
radio because he made people feel when
he was communicating with them that he
was talking to them individually you
know people would be sitting in their
living room or in their kitchen looking
at the radio but they felt somehow he
was just talking to them there's a story
about a construction worker going home
one night as partisan were you going so
early he said well my president he's
coming to speak to me in my living room
tonight it's only right I'd be there to
greet him when he comes it's that sense
of keeping that connection to higher up
you go the more it likely it is to
narrow the numbers of people that you
see and all of these people reached out
across those barriers to keep fresh even
when Eleanor Roosevelt came back from
her stories the what what the people
were feeling in the country they would
always have dinner the first night so
the story would be fresh not repeated
over time you mention Eleanor you also
mentioned Lady Bird Johnson
are there any first lady stories or
attributes that that you think don't get
enough air time or that perhaps are our
lesser-known that should be better known
well I think the important thing is that
the importance of a First Lady and so
far we have had just first lady snow for
the importance of a first lady to the
president goes well beyond whether they
contribute in the partnership way that
Eleanor did I mean she was extraordinary
she's the first lady to ever have a
radio program the first lady to speak at
a national convention the first to hold
weekly press conferences where she had a
rule that only female reporters could
come to her press conferences so that
all over the country stuffy publishers
have to hire their first female reporter
to go to elinoz press conferences but
they all can't be as active in politics
as Eleanor was in fact when Bess Truman
came in Eleanor said I'll introduce you
to the ladies of the press and Bess
Truman said why in the world I want to
do that I'm not gonna be talking to the
ladies of the press what you need to
know is the same thing you need to know
about any partnership is what are they
contributing to one another Teddy
Roosevelt's wife Edith had no interest
in being a public figure she said the
only time a woman's name should be in
the press is when she is born and when
she dies but she gave him the stability
of a raucous family home the kids were a
part of his life he'd come home and play
with the kids he knew that that they had
a family that was strong and stable and
could withstand any of the pressures of
public life so I think we need to look
at the the way in which the wives and
First Lady's have contributed to their
husbands that may be very different from
political it could be a balance as Lady
Bird was an extraordinary balance to
Lyndon Johnson there were times even
when I was at the ranch where I could
see him get so angry about something and
controlling anger is such an important
part of leadership and somehow as he was
yelling at somebody she could just put
her hand on his knee and say now Linda
and Linda and you don't really mean that
you're gonna feel bad about this later
on and somehow it just calmed him down
so I think sometimes it's somebody who's
come against the manic person sometime
it's somebody like Eleanor who could
actually argue with him and he said she
was like a welcome of thorn in his side
she was the person who could tell him
the truth whenever he needed to hear it
are there any other presidents there
could be someone you have written about
could be someone else you've studied
doesn't even have to be a president a
leader let's just say who strikes you as
particularly under
rated or overlooked and it doesn't have
to be one could be could be more than
one well you know that there's there's
leaders that I don't know about that I
mean that's what's amazing even though I
taught a course on the presidency for
years at Harvard I don't really know a
lot of our presidents in fact right now
I'm involved in possibility of a
mini-series on George Washington and I
can't tell you how little I know about
George Washington which is really
embarrassing but I'm so excited because
now I'll be able to live with him I'll
wake up with him in the morning and
think about him not writing about and it
won't be quite as intense as it would be
but helping us a consultant on this
documentary so I don't think he's
underrated though I think people know
about him but I'm sure if I were to go
into somebody like Cleveland maybe
Grover Cleveland if I went into James
Polk which everybody who knows him says
now he's a really interesting guy you'd
find more about it that's the thing when
you study somebody you get interested in
them and the fact that they reach the
presidency usually means that there's
some ambition there there's some desire
hopefully to do something for the
country there's some resilience because
they've all been through something so
they become human beings and then you
realize that maybe they're underrated as
a person because of their judgement in
history the way presidential historians
judge people can often be difficult I
remember I happen to be at a dinner at
the White House in 1997 so as before
Monica Lewinsky happened to Clinton but
there'd been a presidential historians
poll that came out that day that ranked
him sort of in the middle and he was so
angry through the dinner he just kept
talking about I unfortunately was
sitting next to him as a presidential
historian so I was trying to make him
feel better that very day the owners of
the Brooklyn Dodgers now the Los Angeles
Dodgers had announced that they were
selling the team and there was some
thought that maybe they'd come back to
Brooklyn so I said to I said to
President Clinton I'll make you a
corrupt bargain if you bring the Dodgers
back to Brooklyn I will put you up a
notch on the next presidential poll it
didn't even really laugh I didn't think
he thought it was funny but I thought it
was funny anyway you know just
mentioning that business though of
Lyndon Johnson and having anger
controlling anger
is such an important part of leadership
and both some of my guys were so much
better at it than others I mean Abraham
Lincoln had this wonderful ritual that I
think you can develop where when he got
angry with somebody he would write what
he called a hot letter to the person
releasing all his anger and then he put
the letter aside hoping he would cool
down psychologically and never need to
send it the famous case of that is when
General Meade failed to follow up with
General Lee's army after the victory at
Gettysburg despite telegram saying you
can't let these Lee's army escape he did
let these armies escape and jump and and
and Lincoln was so upset about it that
he wrote a long letter saying I'm
immeasurably distressed you didn't do
what we asked you to do had you done so
the war would have come to an earlier
end but then he realized oh my god he's
still in the field this will paralyze
him he puts the letter aside and it's
never even seen until the 20th century
when his papers are open and a raft of
these kind of letters exists never sent
and never signed so after the book team
of rivals came out a CEO wrote me and he
said thank God for Lincoln's hot letters
he had written an email to a subordinate
thinking that the subordinate had done
something wrong and then he decided I
think I'll just put this in draft
instead of sending it and he found out
the next day that he had been wrong
about the information so that's one way
to get through with pangur FDR had his
own way he would write drafts of
speeches say his fireside chats would go
through five or six drafts before they
would be done and if he was angry at a
congressman over a particular incident
he would call out the person by name in
the first draft you know he called him a
traitor to his class a terrible guy a
new young speechwriter came along and
said I can't believe he's going to do
this this will look terrible the older
speechwriter said just wait till the
second draft buy the second draft the
congressman's name was gone by the third
the negative adjectives were gone by the
final draft all was sweetness in life
but he'd gotten it all out of his system
by doing that so figuring out ways to
get that anger out in a way that's not
going to hurt the person directly and
hurt your own leadership is something
that my guys were able to do Lyndon
Johnson less able to when he'd be angry
he would go for example to somebody's
desk and if the desk was clean anything
oh my god the guy's not working hard if
it was messy he'd think he's
disorganized
and then when he got angry he would just
start yelling at the person right there
and then he'd feel bad and he might send
you know a present to them the next day
but so much better if you can release
that anger in a different way
Stanton Lincoln's war secretary came by
one day and he was furious at a general
and so Lincoln said to him well why
don't you write to the general and tell
him what you're feeling and so Stanton
comes back a few days later and he reads
him the thing and and and he says now
Stanton what are you gonna do about it
he said I'm gonna send it of course and
Lincoln said no you're not just throw it
in the wastepaper basket he said but it
took me two days to write and he said I
know and it did you ever so much good
you feel better now that's all that's
necessary just throw it away
and so after a little more grumbling
Stanton did just that and the
interesting thing is when I when I
interviewed President Obama for a Vanity
Fair exit interview I was talking him
about Lincoln's hot letters and and he
had read team of rivals but we we went
over it again and he said do you ever do
that he said what do you mean of course
I do all the time I said what do you
mean he said I write dozens of letters
and crumble them up and put them in the
wastebasket so that's a lesson one could
learn pulling from that Vanity Fair
piece I wanted to ask you about this
because at one point but I think I have
this right you you wrote at the
beginning you preparing for this
conversation today I realized that it
was nine years ago that you first called
me on my cell phone
quote hello this is Barack Obama I've
just read team of rivals and we have to
talk about Lincoln so a couple of
questions did you know this call was
coming was it blocked number and then
someone's lying there Barack Obama did
do you believe that it was a problem all
right could you tell us a little bit
about that phone call remember he's just
a candidate at this point running way
behind Hillary Clinton but obviously he
had been a star at that convention so I
had never met him but I'd heard him give
that speech because I'd been there
covering it for television but no I've
been picture the room I was in in my
house when I just answered the cell
phone and he said this is Barack Obama
and I thought at first is it really but
indeed it was and what had happened is
that he wanted to talk to me about the
book not because he was thinking of
Korea
a team of rivals he was so far behind
Hillary at that point he just was
fascinated by Lincoln's emotional
intelligence you know how he could
forgive these people in the past how he
could control his anger how he could
share credit all those things so I went
to his Senate office building and talk
to him about Lincoln and then the
interesting thing that happened is that
when he then appointed Hillary Secretary
of State mr. chief rival after he had
won the nomination actually somebody
asked him a journalist said to him would
you really be willing to put one of your
chief rivals into your cabinet even if
he or she had a spouse who could be pain
in the neck of course it was meaning
Hillary and Bill Clinton and he he then
quoted Lincoln and he said you know the
times are in peril you know these are
the strongest most people if she's the
strongest yes I'll put her in so then
when he did it sort of became a term
team of rivals so when I went to the
inauguration covering it for television
and there was a party the night before
where Hillary Clinton was and teasingly
she came up to me and said you are
responsible for my being Secretary of
State
of course not me but Abraham Lincoln but
yes I think leaders do learn from each
other that one of the great things about
Harry Truman was that even though he was
not college-educated he loved reading
history and biography and he learned
from the leaders in the past I mean each
one of them I think learns from each
other I mean when I think about it the
book that I've written about Lincoln and
Teddy and Franklin and LBJ it's almost
like a family tree because LBJ's hero
was Franklin Roosevelt's who he called
his political daddy Franklin Roosevelt's
hero was Teddy Roosevelt in fact he
modeled his whole career on him when
when Franklin was 28 years old and a law
clerk as I say not having been a great
student or even a great law clerk he and
the law clerks are sitting around and
talking about what might happen to them
in the future he said I'm not going to
be practicing law forever I think what
I'd like to do is to be a state
legislator and then I think I'd love to
be assistant secretary of the Navy he
loved ships and he loved maps he loved
the Navy and then maybe from that I
could be governor and then who knows
maybe I could be president exactly the
path that Teddy Roosevelt's had taken
and Teddy was his hero they were
distantly related but of course Eleanor
Roosevelt was Teddy Roosevelt's younger
brother's daughter and her father had
died of alcoholism young so Teddy became
a real
uncle to her so from the time that
Franklin was young meeting the family
early on and then from knowing Teddy
Roosevelt young man that was his hero
Teddy Roosevelt's hero was Abraham
Lincoln and he used to read he read one
summer when he was in the middle of this
terrible crisis of the coal strike he
read the volumes eight volumes by nickel
and hey on Lincoln it just helped him he
said to learn that Lincoln had been
through rough times before that Lincoln
had had to face radicals on the one side
conservatives on the other and figure
out a moderate point of view and in the
middle of this coal strike he's reading
this book and it gives him solace and
then of course
Lincoln's heroes were the founding
fathers and George Washington so it
shows how short the history of our
country is that you can encompass these
four or five leaders in the whole
history of the country who form a family
tree it is remarkable it's it's it
really is incredible I mean not just I
think about say traveling overseas and
you find these buildings that are by not
a small margin so much older than the
entire history of our country it's it's
really remarkable and I'd love to come
back to some of these habits one of
which we discussed the hot letters say
that Lincoln would write are there any
other routines or habits could be for
anything for forgiveness sharing or
giving credit or anything at all that
have stuck with you that you find
particularly interesting or unusual from
any of the figures you've studied well I
think you know one of the things that
Teddy Roosevelt would argue was that
procrastination was a mortal sin so that
if he knew he had to give a speech
months away he would start writing it
that day just so that he wouldn't have
to think about when am I gonna start it
when am I gonna start it even when he
was leaving the presidency he was
supposed to give a speech in the
Sorbonne after his year in Africa on the
hunt that he went on but he had already
finished the speech before he went even
on the hunt to Africa and so there's so
many times even for myself if I have
something I really don't want to do I at
least start
so that I won't have to think what am I
gonna start that thing so that's a habit
that I think he developed in his other
people in the cabinet whenever they had
to give a speech or go somewhere they
would all be preparing ahead of time and
sharing drafts with one another which
they wouldn't have done if it had waited
til the last moment I think the most
important thing however that they all
figured out how to do was how to relax
and replenish their energies to find
time to think and relax you know I think
about it in our 24/7 world so many
leaders or even regular people working
in an organization feel I can't take a
vacation or I have to take my email with
me wherever I go
I can't find time to do anything else
other than work but think of these guys
that I'm studying they certainly had
difficult situations you had Lincoln
having to deal with the Civil War
you have Teddy dealing with the
Industrial Revolution and the huge gap
between rich and poor that arises during
that time and big labor strife you have
obviously FDR with the depression in
World War 2 and Lyndon Johnson with the
civil rights struggle and here they go
Lincoln goes to the theater more than a
hundred times during the Civil War and
people criticized him for it they said
how can you go to the theater in the
midst of all this and he said I've got
to get out of politics and out of the
war and for a few hours when I'm
watching Henry the fourth I can imagine
myself back at the War of the Roses and
I must have some relief from this
terrible anxiety it will kill me and the
theater is in or for Lincoln when he
told funny stories he was a great
storyteller and he could tell stories to
people who were around him and they'd
laugh and when he would laugh somehow he
was whistling off his sadness so humor
in a certain sense was his way of
dealing with anxiety Teddy Roosevelt
every afternoon found time two hours
every afternoon for either a raucous
tennis match or a strenuous hike in the
wooded cliffs of Rock Creek Park or
being thrown around by two Japanese
wrestlers or boxing that he loved
playing this game single-stock he would
often injure himself in these various
games he played and then there was one
time when he was in the middle of the
coal strike where he was deprived of
these any exertion zhh because he had an
infected leg so he writes to the
librarian of Congress and he said I need
some escape from all this I want you to
send me something on Mediterranean
history or something on the history of
Poland and so in the middle of this coal
strike at night he says and he writes
back to the librarian of Congress and he
said it's been such a delight to drop
everything useful everything relating to
my duty particularly the coal strike and
spend an afternoon reading about the
relations between Assyria and Egypt
which could not possibly do me any good
but in which I reveled accordingly I
Franklin is the best I think in some
ways he's the best so first of all he
loves going to having movies at the
White House he loves crossword puzzles
he loves his stamps he loves looking at
maps he loved playing poker he really
really knew how to relax but the best
thing he did was when he was in World
War two he had a cocktail hour every
night and the rule was that you couldn't
talk about the war you could talk about
books you'd read you could talk about
movies you'd see in goss him about
people as long as the war wasn't
mentioned so for a few precious hours he
liked Lincoln when Lincoln was at the
theater could relax totally and after a
while this cocktail hour was so
important to him that he wanted his
closest friends and associates to be
living on the second floor of the White
House to be ready for the cocktail hour
so the White House became the most
exclusive residential hotel you could
possibly imagine
Harry Hopkins his foreign policy adviser
came for dinner once slept over didn't
leave until the war came to an end
his secretary Missy lehand lived with
the family in the White House I'm Lorena
Hickok who had an emotional relationship
with Eleanor had a bedroom next to
Eleanor and the princess from Norway and
exile in America during the war lived
with the family on the weekends and the
great Winston Churchill came and spent
weeks at a time in a room diagonally
across from Roosevelt's so when I was
writing the book I just imagined all
these people in their bathrobes at night
on the corridor of the second floor of
the White House waiting for the cocktail
hour or having come from the cocktail
hour and then being ready for bed and
and wishing that when I'd been up there
with Lyndon Johnson when I was 24 I'd
asked where did Roosevelt sleep where
was Eleanor where was Churchill but I
wasn't thinking in those terms then so I
happen to mention this on a radio
program in Washington when no ordinary
time came out and it happened Hillary
Clinton then in the White House was
listening so she promptly called me up
at the radio station invited me to sleep
overnight in the White House so I
couldn't wander the Carter together with
her and their husband and think
out where everyone has slept fifty years
are all here amazing she invited me and
my husband to sleep overnight and we
were given Winston Churchill's room
which meant there was no way I could
sleep I was certain he was sitting in
the corner drinking his brandy and
smoking his cigar but my map we figured
out yes Chelsea Clinton is sleeping
where Harry Hopkins was and the Clintons
are sleeping where FDR was and of course
we were with Winston Churchill so the
exciting that is amazing
are there any particular routines tools
anything that you use to rejuvenate or
decompress yourself you have an
incredibly busy schedule or you
certainly just based on the amount of
work you put out it would seem that you
are certainly able to go go go so what
have you built into your schedule to
help recharge the batteries once it's
time for dinner
I don't work late into the nights I work
I get up early in the morning I can wake
up at 5:00 or 5:30 I love getting up
before everybody else does he is around
and I don't look at email until 7:00 or
7:30 if it's winter I come downstairs
and I have a fire that I can turn on a
fireplace if it's summer and it's
air-conditioned I put a blanket on
myself and the rest of the household
hasn't awakened yet so those are really
precious hours to to just read over what
I've written the day before not look at
email not think of everything else I
have to do that day and similarly by
6:30 or so at night that's the end of
work I go out to dinner every night as I
was saying and when I get to that bar
with my friends it has nothing to do
with what I was doing that day we're
talking about the game of the Red Sox so
we're talking about politics and it's
totally taking me away to another
channel of thing and then because we've
had season tickets for the Red Sox for
the last you know thirty years when I
walk into the baseball game I became a
Red Sox fan after the Brooklyn Dodgers
abandoned me and went to Los Angeles and
I moved to Harvard and became a Red Sox
fan equally as crazy as I was as a
Brooklyn Dodger fan but once I walk into
that ballpark and I keep score still and
when I can there I feel like I'm in
another
place and I don't think and worry about
what I'm doing and then when I get home
at night I don't read history at night I
read mysteries somehow that's what I
need to do before going to sleep is to
read some mystery I don't know why China
put the pieces of the puzzle together
but just relaxing with a good mystery so
there are ways to do it I think I mean
it the the most interesting way of
thinking about anxiety for my guys is
FDR had all these ways of allowing
himself to relax he went on a fishing
trip at one point ten-day fishing trip
in the middle of the crisis of Britain
before we were in the war and he came up
with the whole idea of lend-lease on
that fishing trip because he was away
from the turmoil of Washington where the
bureaucratic structure couldn't figure
out how to lend money or lend supplies
to England because of neutrality acts so
he comes up with lend-lease can you
explain what that is I'm gonna my
ignorance I don't know what that is no I
absolutely so what happens is that when
Britain has is already being bombed by
Germany and it's 1940 so it's we're not
in the war yet he knows that Churchill
has run out of supplies Dunkirk had
happened so their destroyers were killed
we need to somehow get our supplies and
our weapons to England but England has
no money to buy them anymore and
neutrality acts say we can't just give
them to them so he comes up with the
idea that we will lend you our weapons
and then after the war is over you will
get them back to us as if neighbor's
house is on fire and you're gonna lend
them your hose to save that neighbour's
house but also save your house too and
then in return for giving the weapons we
got a lease on British bases all around
the world it was really a good deal a
good Yankee bargain but anyway Italy
gave us money for toward Russia it gave
us money for all of our allies not just
money but supplies that were given to
our allies all over the world because of
leasing them rather than letting them
buy it so on this 10-day fishing trip he
comes up with the idea that he can just
lend the weapons and then get them back
at the end and it's really leasing them
rather than selling them or having them
buy it so it was a simple thing but
nobody could figure that out in
Washington
but the thing that really struck me was
that on evenings when FDR couldn't fall
asleep when there was unusual tension
and the poker game didn't do it or the
cocktail hour didn't do it he had this
ritual that helped him to fall asleep he
would close his eyes and imagine himself
as a boy again at Hyde Park standing
with his sled atop the steep hill behind
his house and he would go down the hill
until he reached the bottom and then
slowly come back up again to the top and
then he'd do again go over and over
again it was his method of counting
sheep but the amazing thing is he's also
liberating himself from the paralysis by
this imagining and in that way he falls
asleep so and what the Teddy Roosevelt
would do when he was anxious about an
election and this I've thought about a
lot actually he would write letters to
his friends and his family saying don't
worry if I don't win this election I've
had the best life so far I've had a
first-rate run and it would be selfish
of me to think that if I don't win this
one everything is lost and I've thought
about that a lot actually I've thought
about the fact that if I knew I were
dying and maybe this is a dramatic way
of putting it because he was just
worrying about losing an election but
that I hoped that it would give me
solace to think I really had a good life
and I felt like it was what I wanted it
to be and I can't control that it won't
go on any longer
but I can look back on that just like
Teddy looked back on his life and I
thought about it so much in these last
months because my husband had got cancer
this last year and he was incredible
during the whole time I mean he's he
still even though he couldn't enjoy food
anymore because of the radiation that he
went through couldn't have his trademark
cigars anymore he went out every night
with us to our regular bar dinners even
though he was being fed by a feeding
tube during the day so that he would get
the nourishment he needed and I actually
learned how to you do the feeding tube I
couldn't believe that I learned that I
was so afraid of my technical abilities
when I had to face that fear and somehow
do it but in the days before he died all
of our friends came to visit him because
he was in Hospice at home and somehow
magically he he woke up when people
would comedy had something to say to
them something funny or something
serious
and and then he would go back to sleep
and then wake up again but in in so many
days before that he would say he didn't
necessarily know he was dying right then
but he knew that he had cancer and that
the radiation hadn't worked and he there
was no sense of talking about death he
was still working on a book that he
hoped to finish but he kept saying I
love this town I love what's happened to
our life our kids are great how lucky we
are and I just hope I can say that at
the same way he did it made it made me
less nervous about dying to watch the
peacefulness of the way he handled it
and there was an extraordinary moment I
can't believe I'm really talking about
all this night now but I somehow gotten
into it where the last thing he said to
me he just looked at me and he had this
incredible light in his eyes everybody
said it was almost like magic and he
just said to me you are a wonder I mean
I will take that those words with me the
rest of my life so I just hope I can be
as peaceful and loving as he was as he
faced his own death thank you so much
for sharing that I don't know but it has
something to do with anxiety yeah it's I
mean the the gratitude and appreciation
that you're describing on so many
different levels but first and foremost
I'm sorry for your loss I can't even
imagine what that would be like but I
thank you for sharing that he was great
42 years and of marriage and an
extraordinary life that he had I mean he
was you know he was involved in so many
things that people knew when the
obituaries came out the breadth of it
people had known part of it I mean we
knew he wrote for Lyndon Johnson the
great we shall overcome speech he wrote
Bobby Kennedy's South Africa speech the
ripples of Hope he worked with dealt
with JFK when he was only in his 20s and
worked on some of his famous South
American speeches Al Gore's concession
speech but more important than any of
that he was just involved in policy in
the Great Society and civil rights and
and then he was in the quiz-show
investigation and that was made into a
movie because he was the young guy who
discovered that those quiz shows when
you weren't even born those push shows
were corrupted and and then he wrote a
play about Galileo and Pope Urban the
eighth that was put on in London and in
Boston it was such a such a
wonderfully broad life and he was a
great guy and a great husband and father
to our kids our kids adored him I feel
like I'm unsure of where to go next with
this that was such a beautiful story and
you're such a you're a gifted
storyteller and it seems to go back a
long way you've honed that certainly
over time and you have some of the most
incredible speaking of sports
storytelling some of the most incredible
book blurbs and quotes from admirers of
your work for the this new book
leadership in turbulent times you have
Warren Buffett an incredible collection
of fans who have provided you with words
for this book why why did you write this
book I mean you you have such a keen
sense of the finite amount of time that
we're all given on this planet given
your study of history certainly
mortality your firsthand exposure to it
why why put the time and energy into
writing this book well you know in some
ways I mean I started it five years ago
so the times we're not as turbulent as
they are now but there was a sense that
Washington was broken even then and that
we weren't kind of leadership on the two
sides of the aisle that could get
anything done and having lived through
the 60s having been there when the civil
rights bill passed and the voting rights
bill passed and aid to education
Medicare it was such a thrilling time to
be young to see our country moving
together in those directions I'd written
about these four guys before but I
hadn't really looked at them as leaders
and what it was that made them able to
not just bring two sides of the aisle
together but lead the country through
such difficult times and I realized that
each of the times in which they led are
far worse than the time we're living in
now so that if we think this is the
worst of times history will tell you
know we've had more turbulent times
before and we got through them when you
had the right leader fitted for the
right time I mean that they all had
different leadership styles they
wouldn't have been fitted to be and the
other
possibly so it's not just a matter of
the constellation of traits you have its
whether or not those behavioral patterns
fit the challenges of the moment of the
time but I think what I really wanted to
do is just to understand how they became
leaders I mean we see them as iconic
figures now they're Mount Rushmore
there's monuments and I was giving a
talk to a group of college students you
know four or five years ago and one of
them raised their hands and said but how
can we I was talking about leadership
lessons from the White House but how can
I ever become one of them
it's too far removed so the way I start
the book is when each one of them is
running for office the first time so
they're not formed yet and they're not
going to necessarily succeed Lincoln in
fact loses his first election when he's
23 years old but incredibly he says if I
lose I've been already too familiar with
this appointment to be very chagrined
but I do promise I'll come back five or
six times and try again until it's too
humiliating and then I'll give up that's
incredible that kind of resilience Teddy
Roosevelt adversity and I guess I was
interested in that too maybe because of
my personal history of my mother dying
when I was 15 my father died when I was
in my 20s so that I had encountered
death at an early age but all of these
people went through terrible adversity
Lincoln had a near suicidal depression
when he his word was no longer his bond
he had broke his engagement to marry and
he was humiliating her by doing so he
had failed in bringing infrastructure
projects to Illinois which he had
promised to do and he really was almost
ready he said to die but when he was
told by his best friend you have to
rally or you will die they'd taken all
knives and scissors and razors from his
room he said I would just as soon die
now but I've not yet accomplished
anything to make any human being
remember that I have lived so that was
his lodestar that carried him through
everything all that losses that he had
he tried for the Senate twice he lost he
finally wins the presidency and then he
has the civil war in front of him so
resilience and coming through adversity
was a key that I wanted to understand
and all that happened to all of them
Teddy Roosevelt lost his wife and his
mother on the same day in the same house
in New York his wife was pregnant having
a child the mother had only 49 it comes
take care of her the mother got typhoid
fever and died and the wife died in
childbirth
on the same day in that house and he was
so depressed he left the state
legislature he went to the Badlands he
said he had to be on his horse 15 hours
a day he could out ride black hair
depression but more importantly he found
solace in nature he found solace in the
West and became a different kind of
leader because he understood the West as
well as the East and he came back and
then went on to this extraordinary
political career but it taught him he
said you don't build your resume little
by little he had always thought before
he had a pattern worked out and no
longer did that pattern seem so he said
I'm just going to take whatever job
comes it seems really interesting to me
because it may be my last job because he
now had a fatalism about life so his
friends say why am becoming civil
service commission wine police
commission this is below you he said no
I want to do these things and if it's my
last job so be it and then of course
most importantly FDR I mean what he went
through when he contracted polio and was
paralyzed from the waist down
it allowed him to emerge more
warm-hearted more connected to other
people to whom fate had dealt an unkind
hand then he would have been before that
you know he said if you spend you learn
humility through something like the
polio and the paralysis he said if you
spent two years trying to move your big
toe which is frozen and you finally move
it and you celebrate it then the
precious of the presidency are not going
to get to you what he did it one Springs
by bringing his fellow polios as he
called them to enjoy life again not just
to rehab themselves in the Warm Springs
pool but he would have wheel chair
dances they play games in the soccer
games or badminton games in the pool he
made them learn to live life again even
with the affliction of having been
paralyzed and he emerged a different
person I mean it's extraordinary what he
did and I just on a human level
I found these stories so important to
understand much less because it made
them great leaders I mean when he first
made a appearance after his polio two
years afterwards he hadn't been in
public life he was asked to give a
nominating speech for Al Smith for
president in 1924 at the Democratic
convention and he was very worried about
how he could get from the sea
with his braces locked in place he could
make appear to be walking if he held on
to the arm of somebody his son
strong-armed get to the podium but he
practiced and practiced that distance in
his own library time after time and he
was sweating and he got up to the podium
and he made it and he would practice
even when he couldn't walk at all he
would practice crawling up the stairs
one stair at a time and each stair when
he got hired they'd have a celebration
when you go through that adversity or a
different person at the other end and
Lyndon Johnson what happened to him was
that he had he hadn't a loss in a Senate
race in 1941 and for him it was as big
an adversity as these other things were
because it meant the end he thought of
his political upward climb and sometimes
people don't get through adversity in a
positive way they can go backward and he
then just accumulated wealth and power
and was not as interested as needed one
spin and making lives better for other
people then he had a near fatal heart
attack in 1955 and as you often read
about with other people it changed his
attitude toward his life and he decided
I need something more than power I need
to make that power put to a purpose and
when he did finally get into the
presidency through the death of JFK and
he decided that the first thing he would
go for would be the Civil Rights Act and
segregation in the south everybody said
it's too risky you can't do that you'll
never get through the filibuster and
your presidency will be a failure and
you're not going to be able to win the
next election and he said well every now
and then if you're playing poker you've
got to throw in all your chips so he had
learned that through adversity so I
think what I wanted to do was even
though I knew them as family men I knew
their colleagues I studied the times I'd
studied the substance of their
leadership I wanted to understand how
they became leaders how they got through
adversity how they developed how they
learned from their mistakes and then
finally the last part of the book are
case studies they're pivotal moments in
their histories which are Lincoln's
Emancipation Proclamation which is
actually coming out in a Harvard
Business Review this you know in days
actually the Emancipation Proclamation
has an example of transformative
leadership and then with Teddy its
crisis management leadership of the coal
strike and with FDR its turnaround
leadership with the hundred days and
with
it's surprisingly visionary leadership
for LBJ on civil rights though obviously
there's a coda about the war in Vietnam
where his leadership utterly failed and
was an epic failure of leadership but
even when I was in graduate school we
used to talk about big things like
ambition
where does ambition come from where do
you get a sense of purpose how do you
have meaning in your life these are the
things you'd stay up with late at night
to talk about and I realized that that
was what I wanted to come back to
probably you know this is in some ways a
culmination of 50 years of studying
presidents but it's at a different level
it's a more personal emotional level
about my guys as I call them and I
really it's really stretched me in a way
because it meant drama and history and
literature and not just biography but
other things to try and understand
psychology to understand how they led
and how they became leaders Doris this
is such a gift of a conversation I've
had so much fun and I am completely
certain that this this book is going to
be so incredibly compelling and valuable
to readers because as you said it's it's
taking such a personal lens to the
stories and lessons learned visa vie
these leaders that it transcends
politics and really touches upon so many
layers of the human experience I really
appreciate you taking the time to chat
with me today and share all this and I
enjoyed it so much this is so so weird
to just be looking at this little
picture of your face and I feel like
talking to each other thank you so much
oh it's entirely my pleasure
and I really encourage everybody to take
a look at your new book leadership
subtitle in turbulent times couldn't be
more timely and timeless in at the same
time and I will link to the book of
course two other pieces of your writing
in the show notes everything we've
discussed for people listening will be
in the show notes so you can find links
there
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
and odorous I have to ask you one more
question before we wrap up which is
speaking myself as someone who
occasionally has trouble sleeping
mysteries do you have any mysteries that
you might recommend or types of
mysteries absolutely in fact I just go
on reading one mystery writer you know
it's sort of a binge reading so just
recently it's been John Grisham and the
great thing was that I was already into
John Grisham when a few months ago he
came up to Boston with four of his
friends from old Mississippi including
one who was 80 years old and had a
bucket list of things he wanted to do
and places he wanted to see and they
were all on a bus together and then they
would come to these various places they
went to New York anyway when they came
to the Kennedy Library part of the
bucket list of the older guy was for me
to talk to them for a couple hours so
Grisham was there so it was so exciting
I mean for me just having come into
reading all of his works to be actually
meeting him and hearing him talk about
how he creates a story and and what
sparks his desire to write about a
particular law firm or a particular
medical problem that happened so yeah
there's something about there's
something about mysteries that just
allow me to transport myself somewhere
else so I think wishin is a great I've
read Bill Clinton's new book and I'm I'm
reading John Jake Tapper's book right
now Hellfire Club which is really good
also so I have several of them because
when I'm on a trip I have to take a
paperback because my suitcase is too
heavy so if I'm reading a hardback I
have to have another one going at the
same time but I somehow get to sleep
well no one will ever accuse you of
being an underachiever you are so gifted
at telling stories that are worth
telling and and also doing it's such an
incredible depth of research to piece it
together in a narrative and it and a
story arc that is is easily digested I
really appreciate you doing the work
that you do and once again thank you so
much for the time today I thank you for
yours Wow and to everybody listening
like I said links to everything are in
the show notes
timba blog for such podcast
and until next time thank you for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday event
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by Inc
Tell now use them personally ever since
I wrote the 4-hour workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life and is it an investing
as well the second how can I spend a
little money or moderate money to save
significant
ETL is one of those investments they're
a turnkey solution for all of your
imaginable customer care ease I used I
fell during the launch of the 4-hour
body which was very very involved and
they provided 24/7 customer service for
my land rush campaign because it was
critical for me to take care of every
person who purchased my books who
participated this allowed me to focus on
the things that I am better at my
strengths like the marketing plan that
we've worked on for six months
implemented in that Intel trains their
experience customer service reps to know
your business and your products inside
now and make your customers raving fans
they answer more than a million customer
service requests every year and they can
do so across all platforms including
email phone social media text you can
chat leaving your customers with or
service or just mediocre service which
by the way in a competitive pool is a
huge liability long wait times or
unanswered messages carries a massive
cost and risk to your business until
removes the logistics and headaches of
this type of communication allowing you
to focus on your strengths and grow your
business it can be a real competitive
advantage and I see many many e-commerce
companies and the tech companies
thinking of customer service as a good
enough
check box or an afterthought and just
like Airbnb you design in innovative
ways to be a competitor and to win that
you can do the same thing with customer
service so as a listener of this podcast
you can get up to ten thousand dollars
off the discount ten thousand dollars
off your startup fees and costs by
visiting in telecom forward slash Tim so
check it out for more info go to
intel.com
i NKT al comm forward slash temp
this episode is brought to you by
audible which has the largest selection
of audiobooks on the planet I've used
audible for many years and I have
several audio books to recommend right
off the bat if you're looking for a new
one ready player one by Ernest Cline you
may have heard of it the town of Seneca
by Seneca if you want to hear my
favorite collection of letters of all
time as well as the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman which is a fiction book I
used to reintroduce nonfiction purists
to the beauty and truth and enjoyment of
fiction graveyard book it is incredible
and I like the version that neo leads
himself but the entire ensemble cast is
also fun audible members get a credit
every month good for any audiobook you
the store regardless of price and unused
credits roll over to the next month so
if you didn't like your audiobook no
problem you can exchange it no questions
asked plus your books are yours to keep
with audible you can go back and
re-listen anytime even if you cancel
your membership and for some books again
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman
I've listened many many times you may
even just start over as soon as you
finish it the first time
audible also helps you to listen to more
books by letting you switch seamlessly
between devices picking up exactly where
you left off whether it's on your phone
through your car for the tablet or at
home on Amazon echo whatever you can get
through tons of books hands and eyes
free while doing almost anything so that
is part of the beauty of audio it is a
secondary activity when you're walking
the dog cooking whatever it might be
audible content includes an unmatched
selection of audio books original audio
shows news comedy and much more for
leading audio with publishers
broadcasters entertainers magazine and
newspaper publishers and business
information providers maybe that's what
I am a business information provider and
right now audible is offering listeners
of this podcast a free audio book with a
30-day trial memberships check it out go
to audible.com forward slash tim and
browse the unmatched selection of audio
programs download a title free and start
listening it is super simple go to
audible.com fold slash tim or text tim
to five hundred five hundred on your
phone to get started today check it out
you
you